so this is our second session and in the
first session we spend a bit of time
orienting ourselves in the subject
matter as to why we're studying what
we're studying in this class and how we
will approach our subject matter and
then second part of the our session we
spend together figuring out the issue
that has for as long as I've taught this
course from the start informed or shaped
or puzzled or haunted the discussions in
the class namely the relationship
between religious exclusivism and the
kind of social plurality or possibly
pluralism as a political project that
seems required by globalization
processes we've tried to shed some light
in this and I hopefully it will continue
that discussion as the semester goes on
now today is a designated session for
religion the next session will be for
globalization the two of them are
studied here together so that that's
roughly the plan for the next two
sessions and the heading for our session
today is that of secularization
I think secularization as well as kind
of the obverse of secularization namely
resurgence of religion so what we are
interesting in particular is to look at
what's happening in the context of
globalization within the world of
religions or within the world of faiths
and obviously one topic to discuss and
to look at is the question of possible
secularization partly because there has
been a long-standing tendency to
associate modernity with secularization
and especially folks who think that
globalization is simply extension of
modernity into the onto the whole of the
globe often then associate globalization
processes themselves with secularization
and so this would be our question and to
try to figure out what is happening in
the context of globalization
with the world of of faiths and it's not
just a question of resurgence versus
secularization or demise but it's also a
question of transformation of religions
possibly within the context of
globalization I think what will keep our
eye on maybe not in this session but as
we go along is also what have been
responses of various religions and
religious communities to globalization
processes and you can have those
responses kind of catalogued and mapped
all the way from whole-scale rejection
of globalization as profoundly anti
religious or subverting some of the most
cherished collections of religious
communities and you have these kinds of
responses in different communities
certainly in some Christian communities
as well as in Muslim communities and in
others as well to all the way to the
idea especially within the Christian
tradition that somehow globalization is
a product off is the fruit of a very
fine fruit of some would say of
Christianity itself and then of course
much of it falls in between these these
two kind of differentiated acceptance or
rejections of various elements of
globalization processes we won't have so
much time during this session to discuss
this although maybe in discussion if
some of you are interested in that we
can raise those those questions also a
topic that's gonna be of some interest
to us for this session was we have
assigned to your readings that at least
two of those have a discussion of what
was described as multiple modernity's
basically idea that there's not simple
single way to modernize and especially
in relationship to religion but also
that there are multiple ways in which
modernity has been lived out depending
on cultural circumstances and those
cultural circumstances have often been
shaped by religions now something
analogous can be also said about
globalization itself that there may not
be a single way to globalize but that
the globalization itself as a single
process refracts itself expresses itself
in various localities in a very much
different ways
partly depending on the local culture
and that those local cultures are often
shaped by religious communities that's
going to be also another subject another
way in which we might access the
relationship between faith and
globalization and that would be the
question of how do fades in fact then
influence or shape provide conditions
for globalization processes as you see
from the comments that I've made so far
it's both asking well how does
globalization impact the world of
religion both in terms of its resurgence
possible or demise as well as
transformation and how the world of
religions might impact globalization
processes now that's just to orient us
in this subject matter I think for the
content of the material I wouldn't
presume to speak here with Jose present
so I want to invite Jose Casanova again
one of the one of the not just great
sociologists of religion but great
conversationalist and great public
speakers so it's wonderful to have Jose
again here with us please